le 78 de ce 10 décembre se poursuit avec
de nouveaux invités sur le plateau et
nous allons parler du Téléton le
compteur à l'issue des de jours
d'antenne sur France Télévision
affichait
8165239 € un chiffre un peu moins bon
que l'an passé où la barre des 85
millions d'euros a été dépassée bonsoir
Daniel Bazan coordinateur départemental
du Téléton Daniel Tamam bonsoir à vous
président d'objectif Téléton Manois donc
à Man on va parler de du bilan dans le
département du bilan à Manil Amot aussi
forcément mais déjà une réaction par
rapport au bilan national 4 millions de
moins de récolter est-ce que c'est une
déception forcément est-ce que c'est une
surprise non pas du tout c'est une
surprise oui si on peut dire vu la
conjoncture actuelle c'est ça peut être
une petite surprise on va dire bon on
s'attend il y aura peut-être une petite
baisse au niveau national ce que je suis
à peu près certain c'est vu les les
différentes manifestations que j'ai pu
voir pendant le weekend tout ça
que au niveau des ibelines nous on se
maintient au on va se maintenir à la
même somme de l'année dernière
c'est-à-dire vous devriez pouvoir
récolter combien je dirais que l'année
dernière on a fait 416 530 je reste à
peu près dans les mêmes dans les mêmes
taux plus de 45000 € sont à prévoir du
côté du département des un mot puisqu'on
est dans les chiffres justement allez-y
alors le le chiffre du jour c'est 20500
il est identique à celui de l'année
dernière pil pooil hein euh tout en
sachant que il y a encore quelques
chèqus qui devrai arriver euh à ceci on
ajoute le réveillon du 31 décembre du
Téléton organisé dans ce cadre là euh on
sera similaire à ce qui s'est passé
dernière je suis assez content bon bilan
bon bilan pour cette année dans le
département un peu moins au niveau
national et puis du côté des audimat
aussi on parlait de France Télévision
des deux jours de dant qui ont été
occupé sur les les différentes chaînes
du service public l'odimat qui est en
baisse 1,25 million de téléspectateurs
contre 15 sur l'édition précédente
est-ce que vous avez peur que le le
Téléton mobilise moins aussi à la
télévision par exemple ah ben c'est ce
que je crois que la baisse elle vient de
là ça moi j'en suis des Don li à la
baisse l' de l'udience tout à fait ça je
je suis persuadé que ça c'est sûr que
c'est c'est inquiéant pour la suite
c'est inquiétant aussi pour les
prochaines éditions faut peut-êre Renou
oui peut-être à revoir la façon je ne
sais pas bon parce que depuis 26 ans
rien n'a changé sur le télour je ce que
je peux dire c'est qu'au niveau de la
forceté enfin pour ce qu'on appelle la
forceté c'est les manifestations dans
les diverses villes sont en
augmentationin je vous avais dit l'autre
fois de 86 on passe à
103 le collègue de deselin West a le
même sentiment et au niveau national au
niveau de du nombre de contrats on est
bien bien on audessus du chiffre de
l'année dernière plus d'animation sur le
terrain en tout cas des fonds constants
sur le département voilà en tout cas
déjà sur ce département qui sont qui
sont récoltés un peu moins vous nous
dites c'est en raison de du de
l'audimate plus faible de l'audience
plus faible sur le service public est-ce
que ça vous inquiète aussi peut-être
pour la suite est-ce qu'il faut revoir
le Téléton aussi dans sa formule il y
avait rivalité entre le Téléton et les
miss ça a toujours été ce ça a toujours
été moi je pas je suis pas vraiment
francièement inquiet parce que il y a
des promesses il y a toujours un écart
entre les promesses de don et puis le
chiffre final parce qu'il est encore
possible de donner 36 37 je rappelle le
numéro vous le connaissez forcément par
cœur il est encore possible de donner
tout au long de la semaine prochaine que
pensez-vous tout de même de cette baisse
de cette diminution enregistrée des dons
cette année nous vous avons posé la
question vos réactions dommage dommage
dommage j'ai participé moi-même j'ai
fait un concours de péancle et c'est
dommage ou alors d'prs vous c'est à qui
peut-être je pense que c'est dû à la
crise surtout je pense qu'il y a une
crise il y a une crise on le sent
d'ailleurs on se promène dans les
centres commerciaux et cetera on on voit
beaucoup moins de monde he moi je pense
que c'est relatif il faut d'abord savoir
si les autres associations aussi
reçoivent moins de dons et bah ensuite
voir si les individus en soi
s'investissent plus dans les
associations ou si au contraire ils
préfèrent donner disons que si on va
réfléchir à la question c'est pas grave
parce que si on veut on peut ils peuvent
aider parce que là avec tout ce qu'ils
vont dépenser comme argent pour Noël et
tout faut penser autrui mais le problème
c'est que est-ce que maintenant les gens
ils pensent à autrui je pense que les
gens maintenant ils ont tellement de
trucs à payer que à la fin de l'année
c'est ils devrai pas le faire à la fin
de l'année peut-être que les gens ont
peut-être moins d'argent à proposer mais
qu'ils appellent quand même pour pour
faire des dons moins importants
peut-être qu' a il y a toujours autant
de donneur mais que les dons sont moins
importants et et c'est vrai que c'est
conjoncturel on peut s'attendre à ce que
ça progresse dans les années à venir
effectivement pour comparer le budget
pour les cadeaux pour les ménages
français sur la fin d'année va se
maintenir voir légèrement augmenté et
c'est pas le cas du côté des asso
assation ça a un petit peu chuté bien
évidemment il reste il reste la crise
mais peut-être on se tourne moins en
tout cas vers les associations ben oui
mais bon moi je l'avais dit déjà en
début d'année si on augmente pas le
nombre de contrat on a certaines ville
comme disait Daniel qui sont saturés
donc je crois que si on veut faire
augmenter la le
chiffreut soit présent dans toutes
multiper le le nombre de contrats je
crois que le télétemp soit présent sur
l'ensemble des communes surtout alors
que des fois elle est très présent sur
certaines communes hein je crois qu'on y
a bien travaillé cette année je remercie
toute l'équipe de ce qu'ils ont
fait il y a eu du travail de fait et du
travail qui rapporte parce que quand on
voit le chiffre qui diminue un petit peu
au niveau national au niveau des
ivelines en se maintient on a augmenté
le le nombre de contrats donc la preuve
est là c'est que c'est le nombre de
contrats qui va faire augmenter le
chiffre c'est tout le calcul est simple
de toute façon c'est qu'en fait on vient
de voir une prise de température à chaud
par rapport à à des promesses de dons
mais Daniel l' fait remarquer c'est que
les contrats c'est des gens qui viennent
participer à des activités et ces gens-l
c'est concret le résultat est concret il
y a pas les promesses de c'est vraiment
l'argent récolté que vous avez dans
laent récolé et là là on est constant
c'est c'est c'est bien effectivement
faut qu'il plus de contrat tout à fait
et depuis je ansjà on s'erçoit qu'il a
moins de donateurs les gens sont plus
consommateurs que donateurs donc ben la
force la force du terrain la force TH et
Ben qui où il y a des crêpes il y a des
repas il y a tout ça des animation pour
faire venir les gens et là ils mett la
main en portefeuille et ça vous fait de
l'argent at absolument alors comment
vous les avez attiré cette année pour
obtenir le même chiffre avec 25 he
d'activité nonstop avec avec une marine
qui est qui est une image avec donc
Virginie Lemoine avec Delphine raciné et
puis puis des activités des activités
les gens viennent il participent je sais
que vous aimez pas les classements
est-ce que manilamo s'en sort bien cette
année oui oui oui mais j'ai beaucoup de
villes qui quelle est quelles sont les
communes où le Téléton a bien marché
cette année alors sur les grosses sur
les les gros contraints je là à l'heure
actuelle on peut pas on peut pas donner
de chiffre bon je peux juste donner un
chiffre sur
rbouiller où ils ont doublé
mais c'est le village d'accueil donc
c'est encore différent rembouillé à
doublé son chiffre de l'année dernière
mais si on s'intéresse juste par exemple
à la ville de trappe lorsque vous étiez
venu sur le plateau la semaine dernière
pour annoncer un petit peu ce Téléton
vous nous aviez dit trappe auparavant il
n'y avait rien et cette année j'ai trois
contrats donc trois événements organisés
sur cette il y avait si contraints sur
sur Trump donc
voilàou non non Trump se développe ce
qui me fait énormément plaisir et j'ai
eu l'occasion de ça bien fonctionné sur
TR ça a très bien fonctionné j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer le maire de de
Trump samedi et on va voir pour
travailler sur ainsi que sur encour pour
essayer de faire quelque chose de de
plus grandiose l'année prochaine mais
croyez-moi on est sur le terrain
justement trappe on va s'y rendre tout
de suite et puis ensuite on fait un
détour par Manil pour faire le petit
point sur ce Téléton sur cette éditionan
guillumeamp c'est une première pour le
club de basket de Trapp des paniers au
du Téléton les enfants ont commencé il y
a à peu près 20 minutes et on est en
train de compter les paniers bon il
commence un petit peu à fatiguer ça se
voit mais puis ils sont très excités
donc ça se voit aussi ça pique pas trop
mais ça va venir je pense et oui les
jeunes de trappe et des clubs
environnant auront tenu une heure nombre
de paniers réalisés plus de 2000 grâce à
leur investissement un chèque de 800 € a
pu être reversé au Téléton autre commune
autre ambiance mais toujours pour la
même cause à Manamo l'association
Objectif tél a sollicité la comédienne
Virginie Lemoine de diverses façons je
participe chaque année au Téléton j'ai
toujours fait des des choses une fois je
su mis avec mon
chien faire des reportages à Lyon j'ai
fait toutes sortes de choses et donc de
donner un tout petit peu de son temps
simplement pour pour soi-même bien
reprendre conscience de ça avant même de
rendre hommage à tous les bénévoles qui
eux très sérieusement et
considérablement donnent de leur temps
et rendre hommage au aux malades qui
sont toujours d'une dignité absolue
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel le
tton permet d'avoir des nouveaux
médicaments et bien que la science
avance plus facilement Christophe modu
est atteint de sclérose en plaque sa
mère s'investit depuis de nombreuses
années dans l'Association manoise pour
le Téléton qui compte actuellement 25
bénévoles on commence à travailler en
avril on a des collecteurs on a des
personnes qui s'occupent plus de
l'administratif on a des gens qui
s'occupent de la décoration on a des
gens qui s'occupent de la technique de
l'organisation de la mise en place dans
le gymnase chacun a un rôle bien défini
en fait avec objectif Téléton d'autres
associations participent à l'événement
au programme spectacle de danse
démonstration de sport et activités en
tout genre ils ont un peu fait toutes
les animations qu'est-ce que tu as
préféré tir à l'arc tir àarc et toi
qu'est-ce que tu as préféré ça tu as
gagné quelque chose oui tu as gagné quoi
ça je trouve qu'il y a moins de monde
que l'année dernière oui peut-être la
crise on espère faire mieux que l'année
dernière mais voilà on sait pas vous
avez fait combien l'année dernière qu'on
a une petite idée euh on a fait un peu
plus de 300 € aujourd'hui les bénévoles
de manie peuvent être fiers ils ont
récolté
200452 € presque autant qu'en 2011 mais
il s'agit pour l'instant d'un chiffre
provisoire tous espèrent atteindre et
même dépasser la somme de l'an
dernier et on atteint les 415000 €
environ sur le département des ivelines
voilà pour ce ce point ce qu'on pouvait
dire en ce qui concerne les chiffres
vous préparez déjà la suite vous
soufflez un peu dans quel état d'esprit
vous êteson va s'intéresser peut-être au
bénévoles aussi oui on est serein il y a
pas de problème non mais les bénévoles
sont très contents non pas forcément
fatigué non c'est c'est une bonne
fatigue en toutous les cas il quand on
voit jeune Christophe modui qui qui est
passé là qui qui qui attend attend donc
pour nous c'est notre récompense et ça
ça vous donne l'énergie pour continuer
encore préparer l'année prochaine la
marine cette année ça a été un vrai plus
pour faire venir on l'imagine forcément
comme chaque année des gens du côté de
c'est une image intéressante c'est
difficile de faire venir des des parins
des marines sur les différents c'est
c'est une démarche qui démarre en avril
pas facile c'est pas facile on a on a dû
démarcher plus plus de 100 personnes on
vous souhaite bon courage pour l'année
prochaine alors quelques pistes et en ce
qui concerne le département des des
ivelines vous supervisez à partir de
quand avril aussi ça commence un peu à
Ben nous là maintenant on est en train
de faire donc ce qu'on appelle la les
remonté donc récolter l'argent des
organisateurs et on travaille déjà sur
le le télétan 2013 vous arrêtez JIS mer
ce n'est pas qu'un mois c'est toute
l'année vous ne vous arrêtez jamais
merci à vous deux d'être venu sur le
plateau 415000 € à peu près au niveau du
du département on aura bien sûr
l'occasion de vous donner le chiffre
définitif puisque vous pouvez aussi
donner encore un 36 37 jusqu'au 14
décembre pour le Téléton je rappelle que
2/3 de vos dons sont déductibles des
impôts